so I loved Eastern Promises
and there was always talk for a while
about more in that story it's coming is
it it's written and I've heard that yeah
but is it really coming well funnily
enough as of right now you know as I say
it is like fishing where you leave it
out there and it's been out there for a
while and it went through permutations
in the sense of you know how do you
follow Vigo so we've been through that
when we've moved on and now we're in a
position where I will say watch this
space but we're close to getting into
production really yeah and is this gonna
be so it's not with Vigo though no and
it's a I mean I you never know and who
do you have a director yes I can't
really talk about this yet but yes I
don't want to in trouble no we do have a
director and when we are at to a couple
of really good actors I completely get
it so you do you think this could
actually be filming this year yes so you
were financing and things
it's just question of lockdown exactly I
got it that's awesome
is it the same script that you wrote a
while ago yeah I mean I was it's changed
a bit and it changed quite recently as a
result of events in the world because of
the topicality of the Russian thing
and so yeah I've adapted it to reflect
recent events I don't want to get you in
any more trouble but I cannot wait
you